cellphone companies are racing to bring
us 5g the next generation of cell phone
service that promises superfast data
speeds but as they spread the service
out thousands of people will be headed
up to install new gear high atop cell
phone towers the coming conversation
conversion excuse me is creating a big
demand for climbers with technical
skills and strong stomachs Kenneth Craig
got a first-hand look at what it takes
to train them Kenneth now I'm wondering
if you went way up high I sure didn't
good morning Dana we recently paid a
visit to that training center near
Dallas and there we met the newest
generation of climbers and got a preview
of the dangerous work they're preparing
for Sebastian Campbell is gearing up for
another day on the job
far from the confines of an office his
work requires a daunting climb up the
side of a cellphone tower that rises
more than 17 stories above North Texas
it's exhilarating it's why I joined this
industry I wanted to do something that
most people just really can do it's a
thrill and thrill seeking he's at this
outdoor training camp with the newest
team of tower hands brought on board by
telecom giant Erickson hired for the
rollout of 5th generation Wireless
better known as 5g they really are it
seems the backbone of all of us
they're absolutely critical to our
business and it's why we're making this
investment here we can't do 5g in North
America without our people who climb
without our teams that work out in the
field but Matt Jones who oversees
regional operations for Ericsson in the
central US says there is a major
shortage we need to double in size we
need to take our climbing community and
we need to grow it coast-to-coast
in every state that we work in why is it
so difficult to find these kind of
workers the works not easy
physically it's demanding it's outside
more than anything it's at height we
have a lot of our people that work at
Heights off between a hundred feet and
up to 350 400 feet on a daily basis
so you've got to be willing to climb
you've got to be comfortable once
they're up there and you've got to be
physically able to do it
and this is where they take their first
steps at a 13,000 square foot training
camps and I have to pull the rope by the
way in Lewisville Texas we met Brody
Lewis during his first week of climbing
school I'm an active person and I love
to be outside today I want to put a suit
on every day and go do a desk job and do
the same thing over and over
he's a former Marine who made the move
during his transition out of the
military and he's not alone started
climbing hundred foot towers in
Afghanistan after time in a classroom
students strap in for hands-on training
where climbers learn how to install
maintain and repair the equipment that
can deliver a 5g signal everybody turn
to your right
check the person that's in front then
it's time for the real deal when you got
the ropes up here you want to make sure
that they're not tangling Timothy
Armstrong is a senior trainer this is
what's keeping you this is what's gonna
protect you and save your life yeah this
is at the end of the day you have to
trust your gear and this is what's gonna
save your life when you're up there on
the tower wearing at least 50 pounds of
gear it's a stomach dropping journey to
the top Matt Jones who's a former
climber himself says it's not only a job
with a view you can see for miles and if
the weather is good yeah it's awesome
being up there but also one with the
future it's not gonna be the end there
are more G's to follow and that's why
this is a long-term investment for us
this isn't something that we're turning
around just for that a couple of years
of a 5g deployment this is the way our
industry is going and it's a commitment
we've made to be successful in that
space and we met some students down in
Texas who had no climbing experience at
all and Erickson says you really don't
need it you just have to be willing to
give it a go and most importantly work
at Heights certainly not forever yeah
you had to do the training in order to
go that yeah they said it can I go up on
the tower they said sure you can take
the four-week course and strap in and
get on but we didn't have that kind of
time it looked like everybody was pretty
buff and ready five of the people we met
were former Marines yeah very
interesting story kind of thank you